tout va bien Jean-Mi
occupe-toi de ton émission Thierry merci
mon nouveau chroniqueur un autre regard
sur le monde tout va bien Jean-Mi dis
donc il devait pas y avoir scarlett
Johansson
non c'est Margot
on passe maintenant à la question de
Jean-Mi
[Musique]
j'en ai
alors j'ai envie que tu as préparé une
question pour Michel Onfray Michel tu es
un bourreau de travail et tu publies
quatre cinq livres par an tu fais
comment tu es un robot
c'est-à-dire que je travaille tout le
temps donc jamais vraiment
des prises de notes des lectures des
plans et puis un moment donné où quand
je me mets à travailler j'ai
l'impression d'être un robot mais quand
je vois le robot j'ai pas l'impression
que ce soit la bonne métaphore il a
l'air tellement humain
et inquiétant
regardez comme ça
je n'en sais rien pas tout
bon Jean-Mi ça te va comme réponse la
réponse de Michel Onfray on aura pas
mieux de toute manière
[Applaudissements]
un jour je prendrai ta place chérie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu